bien d'autres sujets sur lesquels jouent
les je voulais revenir parce que je
savais pas qu'il y avaient autant qui en
a créé après on va doubler je n'ai pas
les mêmes va rejoindre toute l'équipe il
a plein d'autres programmes maria valdes
et on va parler d'autres pros on va
parler de plein de choses on va aborder
tous les sujets il ya tellement de
sujets abordés ce soit c'est je le dis
souvent dans l'émission je vous le dis
et j'ai été dur avec vous je vous dis
monsieur mélenchon j'ai été très dure
avec vous allez à calgary dois de vous
le dire c'est sur vos propos sur le
christ alors débaptiser le crif s'est
alors sur les la notation des
institutions lui voilà qui se crispe ce
délai les vrais ce que vous avez dit le
trip c'est oui qu'est ce que ça veut
dire c'est des initiales oui c'est le
conseil représentatif des institutions
juives de france
je suis pas d'accord avec le nom alors
ça commence bien mais parce qu a pas
d'institutions juives en france il ya il
ya des associations il ya des mais
qu'est ce que c'est les institutions les
institutions c'est celle de la
république pas d'une communauté mais oui
alors à l'élection même plat dessus là
dessus moi jouions moche hui ouais je
suis juste d'origine tunisienne est dans
mes émissions jeunes vraiment la parole
à tout le monde et j'essaie d'être le
plus juste possible
ça me donne rapport non mais c'est non
mais c'est évident mais c'est d'abord
une personne exactement
voilà je suis d'abord une personne oui
je suis voilà je suis je me sens autant
tunisiens que juifs et que je pense que
si j'ai fait ce parcours c'est ma
culture tunisienne qui me l'apporté et
ma culture juive et c'est vrai que moi
je suis comme vous
j'aime pas tous ceux qui qui stigmatise
les musulmans il en a beaucoup et je
laisse souvent et nous du rejet mais je
tue dans mon émission
xala le 5 mai plus gros combat au lit et
j'ai trouvé qu'ils aient eu il ya eu des
dérives aller sur la communauté de moi
oui je dit quoi jeudi ses skis ressenti
non non non non si mes propos sur le
canon soyez directs crochets clairement
à chaque fois que à chaque fois voilà
chaque fois que le crif fait des sorties
ou du tabac c'est le christ est toujours
les mêmes
ces voix là ils sont d'accord entre moi
et c'est pourquoi quelqu es vote parce
qu'il ya un problème politique du crif à
mon égard pas de moi les gars du crif
mais au début
j'ai même allé une fois ils m'ont invité
au dîner j étais bon ne lui remettrait
plus les pieds mais roy mais parce que
c'est d'une véhémence d'un sectarisme
est d'abord depuis quand le crif
représenterait tous les juifs de france
c'est nouveau ça il y en a même pas un
sur cent qui votent pour ce truc non
mais donc nous avons à présent mais je
vous dire comment s'était même dit que
si vous voulez je vais vous dire une
chose pour plein de raisons
l'antisémitisme est pas dans mes moyens
d'accord donc pour plein de raisons donc
vous va laisser tomber ça le crif a
justement cette attitude insupportable
parce que d'accrocher la pancarte
d'antisémite à tous ceux qui sont pas
d'accord avec amassé sept mon quartier
de bangkok où moi je voulais en parler
avec vous mais vous et je vous remercie
de vous voulez qu'on crève l'abcès là
dessus parce que il ya plein de gens qui
me tue mars moi je vous le dis je suis
plein de gens sur ce qu'ils m'ont dit tu
vas recevoir cet antisémite de mélenchon
si vous aussi je pensais sincèrement
vous étiez antisémite ou raciste ou
islamophobe
oui oui vous ai montré ma vie tu aimais
bien sûr est ce que je veux pas tout
mais vous avez raison et si c'est ma psy
c'est marine le pen qui meurent mais je
l'inviterai faut dire faisons le ménage
vous remercie de pas parce que j'en ai
par dessus la tête et si vous savez
c'est cette étiquette si vous saviez oui
mais c'est dégueulasse d'avoir fait ça
mais je vous dis c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait le crif méthodiquement
systématiquement je vais vous dire le
problème qui avec ce type parce que ce
type d'organisation parce que c'est pas
la seule organisation qui représente ou
qui regroupe deux des juifs en france
pourquoi c'est eux qui auraient la
parole officielle il ya des émissions il
ya des chaînes de télé il ya il ya plein
de choses où je m'exprime et revenons
sur saab ont fait mal d'avoir cette
étiquette ça me fait très mal
ça m'a mis les larmes aux yeux je vais
vous donner un exemple quand je suis
allé à la manifestation à la mémoire de
madame mireille knoll qui a été
assassiné pour un motif a senti ses
mythes
nous avons fait un appel de tous les
groupes de l'assemblée nationale le mien
tout le monde a signé l'appel
nous sommes allés à la manifestation
nous avons appris qu'il y avait une
organisation qui s'appelle ligue de la
défense juive qui est considéré comme
une organisation terroriste aux etats
unis et en israël donc pour au moins on
peut penser que je n'exagère pas en
disant il ya un problème nous avons
appelé le crif c'est pas moi c'est
corbières qui a fait ça qui a appelé le
président du critt et qui lui a dit
écoutez ce que vous
aventis et tu aura pas d'incidents parce
que nous on voulait aller à la marche en
hommage à quelqu'un et qui a été
assassinée on y va pour se disputer se
battre ou je sais pas quoi
à peine était j'arrivais que cette
fameuse ligue de défense nous a insultés
jusqu'à nous expulser de la marche
nous étions en écharpe tricolore mais
moi ce que je veux dire 'attendez cyril
hanouna parce que comme ça j'en profite
pour vider l'abcès comme vous dites non
seulement le crif ne m'a pas défendu
alors qu'on avait prévenu on le dit mais
écoutez garantie c'est nous notre
sécurité
à la fin c'est la police qui nous a
expulsé nous pas les violents alors vous
comprenez moi j'ai fait l'effort pardon
cyril et chaque artiste
j'ai fait l'effort sur le moment de dire
je ne confonds pas 40 énergumènes avec
les juifs de france et jeudi dans le
plus petit village perdu de france bleu
un juif qui serait menacée je serai avec
lui pour l'aider
par conséquent c'est insupportable de
m'avoir accrocher cette pancarte je
pense qu'il ya eu un côté malfaisants
vicieux tordu à vouloir à tout prix
comme ça montrer du doigt les gens vous
trouvé qu'à passer d' antisémite comme
ça faut en inventer un autre mois en
plus moi enfin où on va alors par contre
il ya un problème on ait parlé soit ce
que vous savez que c'est un truc qui
vous colle à la peau ah ben je suis je
savais pas que c'était à ce point là si
vous m'en parlez c'est que je n'en mets
qui fait ça qui fait ça je vous dis que
les oiseaux voilà donc c'est de la
limonade et parler ouais ouais ça merci
c'est au genou dont l'inconscient
collectif donc ce soit fallait qu'on en
parle
ouais mais un collectif de qui je sais
c'est honteux de faire ce à quoi on sait
bien qu'on en ait parlé away je suis
content qu'on en ait parlé ça m'a permis
de dire ce que j'avais à dire et je je
je je veux dire que chaque fois qu'il y
aura une bataille contre le racing vous
comprenez je serai là pourquoi parce que
dans ma vision de la vie 1 vous
connaissez mon âge
donc j'ai eu le temps de vivre 69 way de
vivre de connaître moi je n'ai rien
afficher votre religion vous parle
franchement ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
personne que vous êtes
c'est ça qui compte alors il ya des
juifs sympa les juifs caffier naissant
pas ne passant pas des méchants des
cruels des gentils salah est de même des
chrétiens et surtout 60% de la
population de ce pays qui n'a pas de
religion bien précis il en fait c'est ce
qu'ils disent
parce que quand ils vieillissent et qui
s'approche de la cascade finale en
général
la religion ou et bien sûr c'est vrai
mais et puis il faut le comprendre ça
fait partie de l'humanité alors vous
comprenez que dans ma vision de la vie
ce qui compte ce sont les personnes
l'humanisme qui aiment à bréau ces
journées c'est bien qu'on en humanisant
la philosophie humaniste dit l'être
humain et créateur de sa propre histoire
c'est pour ça que c'était une rupture
avec les religions à l'époque parce que
les gens disaient mais pas du tout c'est
pas l'être humain qui est créateur de
son histoire c'est dieu